Rod's world hey what's going on guys
it's rob and welcome to my tutorial for
thee we look a rubber ball popper the
rubber ball popper is really fun to
either set off launch things or even
scare people sometimes though you have
to be careful because it can pop up
suddenly you need to wear glasses or
goggles when you're using it you'll also
have to use a knife to cut the ball in
half and a scissors in order to modify
it so be sure to ask your mom and dad if
you're not old enough to help you out
I'm going to be using hand bowls to make
the rubber ball popper however you can
use tennis balls or other types of
rubber balls I would recommend using a
used ball and if you have more than one
it's good because something like this
can happen if you're not careful and
then it goes to waste basically once you
have the rubber ball the scissors and
the knife as well as the glasses you're
ready to go alright guys so let's get
started you're not going to need the
scissors right now so let's put those
aside I'm going to recommend that you
use a serrated knife just like this that
doesn't have a sharp end and the reason
is not only is it safer but if you do
use a knife like this which has a very
sharp blade and you try to cut the ball
what will happen is it actually doesn't
cut it very well and will actually cause
it to rip okay so you want to use a
serrated knife just like this you take a
close look at the ball you'll
notice that it actually has a line that
divides the ball all the way in half
okay
and we're going to be cutting along this
line now I know you guys can see it but
I'm going to actually draw on the line
with a pen so that it's easier for me to
see and for you to see as well okay so
there we go
now we're going to take the knife and
also what you want to do is just be
careful it's going to make a mess it's
going to be a lot of powder and stuff so
if you do not want to do it and make a
mess inside the house you can do it
outside or you can put something down I
wouldn't use a piece of paper because
it's going to move all over it's
actually going to make it more dangerous
but just put something down so that it
won't make a big mess
okay then I'm going to set the ball down
and holding it steady I'm going to take
the knife and I'm going to set it right
on that line and I'm basically just
going to stall the ball in half now what
you can do is once you've kind of gotten
a little bit deep inside that inside the
ball we can rotate the ball a little bit
and there we go I actually got inside of
it okay
so then I'm just gonna keep on cutting
along the line
okay let's rotate it again it's a little
bit harder to cut once you've kind of
cut it open a little bit so just be
careful there goes the desk okay so now
that you have the ball cut in half this
is why you don't want to do it on your
desk that was kind of silly anyway now
that I have the ball cut in half I'm
going to go rinse it off okay so as
you'll see I didn't do a very good job
of cutting and a half and you'll notice
that it is very difficult to cut the
ball exactly in half even if you draw
that line so don't worry about it if you
take a close look this one actually has
a tear here so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take the scissors and I'm
going to try to cut that tear out so
that when I flip it inside out it
doesn't rip it
okay and just to double-check what
you're going to do is just pull on it
like this all the way around to make
sure that there aren't any tears and it
doesn't look like there's any more that
might become one now okay let me just a
little bit okay so that's that's not bad
so it's actually holding its form but
what you'll notice is that when you turn
it inside out it immediately pops out
what I'm going to try to do to see if it
I can make this work is turn it inside
out and I'm going to basically squeeze
it like this I'm going to turn it this
way then this way then this way and then
I'm going to set it down and just watch
your head when you put this down because
it's going to pop up
okay so this one is really no good to
use so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to try the other half and you'll see on
the inside it's a lot easier to see that
midway point so I'm going to basically
cut around that line and remove the
excess rubber and you want to remove the
rubber a little bit to the left of that
line so that it's a little bit less than
half of the ball
all right so there we go that actually
looks pretty good okay so I'm just going
to check to make sure that when I pull
on it there's no rips that's going to
tear the whole thing in half all right
it looks pretty good so let's try this
one okay not bad so it didn't go off so
what I'm going to do is to put my hand
over it and just push okay and that will
set it off without it being dangerous so
what I'm going to do is you can do one
of two things you can turn it inside out
and just leave it like that and you can
actually let it sit for hours or even
overnight to see if it will eventually
go off you can also try to bend it this
way you can then gently flip it inside
out and I set it down on the table okay
so that thing won't go off out of
nowhere it's not going to go off in like
two seconds like the other one did so
I'm actually going to remove a little
bit more rubber and if you'll hold it
like this look for areas that are a
little bit excess like right around here
there's a little bit of excess that I
can remove just a very small amount
should do now I'm going to try it again
all right there we go so that's good so
it went off a little too quickly so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to push
right in the middle while pulling on the
ends to flip it inside out and I'm
actually going to press like this and
pull these two edges together while it's
turned inside out and that will actually
make it take a little bit longer to go
off so just go like this back and forth
and you can actually take it between
your two fingers and rub it like that
then set it down and you'll notice it
won't go off as fast even though it just
went off in a few seconds it may take
over a couple minutes to go off now and
you can time it so I'm actually just
gonna not bend it so much gently turn it
inside out
alright that wasn't bad that was about
15 to 20 seconds and that's acceptable I
like that I don't want it to go off in
about two seconds which happens with
some of the other ones that I have so
I'm going to try it again just very this
time I'm going to actually squeeze it
this way which is supposed to make it go
off faster turn it inside out very
gently until it's just inside out set it
down there we go that was about what two
three seconds that's not bad
so you can make it go off faster by
squeezing it like this while it's not
inside out like that or you can make it
go off much slower by turning it inside
out and then squeezing it like this in
between your fingers and that will make
it take a lot longer okay as you'll see
and then if you want to stop it just put
your hand over it and push okay and
there you go that's how to do the rubber
ball popper guys thank you very much for
watching my tutorial for the rubber ball
popper I hope you enjoyed it I have a
lot of fun with these things and I think
you will too practice squeezing it this
way to make it go faster or squeezing it
inside out like that to make it go
slower and trying to find a balance so
that you can know you know how
how hard to push it so that you can make
it go up in a certain time if you did
enjoy the video please be sure to give
it a thumbs up or a like down below
there's a subscribe button down there
that's red if you're not subscribed and
silver if you are and if you are you're
the bomb
Lila thinks you should subscribe she
does if you just want gonna leave her
alone just real quick
don't forget you can also launch it off
your thumb and you can also turn it
inside out like this put something in
here like a little bowl of clay and then
let it flick out just like I did in the
beginning again thank you very much for
watching and I'll see you next time